[Music]
the want is tom parker dead at 33.
the british irish boy band singer has
died after battling an inoperable brain
tumor tom's wife kelsey confirmed the
sad news revealing he died on wednesday
with family and friends by his side he
leaves behind two kids two-year-old
daughter aurelia and one-year-old son
bodhi kelsey shared the devastating loss
on instagram writing quote our hearts
are broken tom was the center of our
world and we can't imagine life without
his infectious smile and energetic
presence we are truly thankful for the
outpouring of love and support and ask
that we all unite to ensure tom's light
continues to shine for his beautiful
children tom's bandmates max jay siva
and nathan were also by his side when he
died the group posted a tribute to their
instagram page praising tom as their
brother and writing words can't express
the loss and sadness we feel always and
forever in our hearts i'm glad you came
i'm glad you came
originally shared his diagnosis back in
october 2020 but said he wasn't giving
up and that he was going to fight this
so glioblastoma is
it's a brain cancer
there's different levels and different
stages of glioma ascension
and i've got the worst one
great
plus life into perspective i think
that's what it does ultimately you know
nothing's ever guaranteed tomorrow is
never guaranteed for anybody
tom's rise to fame started in 2009 when
the wanted was first formed in 2011 they
released their breakout single glad you
came followed by a string of other hits
like chasing the sun and i found you
[Music]
after achieving musical success with the
wanted and even doing a brief stint on
reality tv
we are the one thing
we have briefly moved from the uk to
america to record the next album and see
what trouble we can get ourselves into
best friends forever the band took a
hiatus in 2014 but fast forward to
october 2021 and the group reunited
[Music]
i'll never forget it tom and the guy
spoke with e.t about their first new
music in seven years and plans to tour
the uk in 2022. how does it feel to be
reunited we are back baby we're just
happy to be back together and putting
music out and doing a tour looking
forward to just the future really and
see where it takes us and tom couldn't
help but gush over how therapeutic it
was to sing with the band amid his
health battle it's been really lovely
because not only has it been a great
distraction
but it's just been nice to just
be around love and support and just
positivity yeah you know because this
illness can
very easily and quickly drag you down
and
you know just the boys came around at
just the right moment
they really did to pull me up from the
depths